[Musique]
oui mais bon à part elle atteint 7,6 et
melissa maulin dupuis alors cette
semaine je vous étonnerai pas en vous
disant que le sujet de l'heure c'est
vraiment un quatrième vague du clavier
qui vient de commencer la situation qui
n'est pas clair dans les milieux urbains
dans les écoles et les magasins dans les
jim le passeport matinale tout ça a fait
beaucoup le tour des médias
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup par lancer
l' approche auto des communautés
éloignées et la vulnérabilité justement
de ces communautés la face à la
quatrième vague des taudis faut pas
oublier que trois premières vagues de
convives ont eu lieu ces vagues l'on
était vraiment pris d'assaut par les
communautés pour protéger les ennemis
communauté donc il ya vraiment eu en
place un système on a fermé des fois les
communautés les a rendus inaccessibles
aux membres ou non membres de la
communauté donc beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts ont été mis en place mais bien
sûr cet été a été aveugle et et de
l'espoir beaucoup de gens ont commencé à
faire un peu moins attention à soi
beaucoup plus et c'est là qu'on a vu une
augmentation des cas de coville lors
d'événements justement communautaire
d'événements de rassemblement et une
nouvelle en particulier notre chine
nouvelle des territoires du nord-ouest
un endroit où justement le club des très
peu
comment on pourrait dire de victimes est
bien la première le premier décès a été
enregistré c'était un aîné de 92 ans de
la nation ça tout donné
il est décédé du coup vite prenez que je
te mentir dans le nord-ouest et c'était
en allant à ce n'est pas le tournoi de
jeux de mains qui est un droit de jeu
traditionnel dans la il était un petit
pc jeux ça a été un événement justement
où il ya eu beaucoup de compassion
beaucoup de cas qui sont ressortis de
ces échanges et il est décédé
malheureusement c'est un éloge n'avaient
pas été vaccinés parce que c'était
extrêmement traditionnel qui est est sur
le territoire lorsque les cliniques de
vaccination sont venus dans sa
communauté
vous pouvez comprendre que de plus en
plus de cas apparaissent dans les
communautés certaines communautés qui
avait réussi pendant les 3 premières va
y avoir aucun cas ont eu d'écho
maintenant parce que justement on a
relâché un peu la tension autour des les
mesures pour protéger tout le vide mais
cependant qu'un autre aspect qui est
empreint aussi de ressortir énormément
et c'est la crise de santé mentale dans
les communautés beaucoup
d'appels à l'aide de tentatives de
suicide et malheureusement aussi
des situations où ces tentatives lors on
malheureusement réussi bien
montre vraiment la faiblesse
éléments qui pourraient exister si des
grosses crises de kovy arrivée dans les
communautés parce que les des systèmes
de santé et surtout dans le grand nord
sont beaucoup plus à risque sont
beaucoup plus
fragiles on parle de pitot qui sont sur
le respirateur par manque de ressources
et on comprendra que faire venir des
ressources du sud ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de d'argent aussi ça
coûte plus cher que si on les fait venir
à montréal par exemple donc au cours des
prochaines semaines c'est sûr que j'ai
un oeil vraiment tourner vers les
communautés m'assurer
qu'on n'oublie pas les communautés
surtout en période d'élection c'est
certain que ça devient un sujet de moins
en moins intéressant
surtout quand on pense par exemple
comment les sujets autour des tensions
ont commencé à diminuer dans les médias
on va beaucoup plus parlé des élections
mais c'est un ton en même temps que
justement la montée de la quatrième
vague donc je vous invite cette semaine
à vous intéresser justement la situation
dans les communautés par rapport aux
soins de santé par rapport au monde
justement d'accessibilité aux soins de
santé et de garder un oeil ouvert pour
pouvoir justement appuyer les
communautés lorsque des situations qui
peuvent être très à très haut risque
pour nos communautés peuvent arriver
comme lors de la crise du h1n1 ou les
communautés justement avait eu plus
problématique à accéder à des soins de
santé ou avoir du support du
gouvernement donc je vous souhaite une
bonne semaine en espérant que vous vous
garder en santé et c'était pas partager
nos chroniques n'hésitez pas non plus à
aller retrouver sous format podcast sur
plusieurs des plates formes dans ce pot
de fer et aillent tous et je vous
souhaite une très belle semaine